It's great to welcome to the program today,
David Sinclair, who's a professor of genetics
at [inaudible]
Harvard medical school as well as the author
of the new book lifespan. Why we age and why
we don't have to, uh, David, so great to have
you on today. [inaudible] thanks David. Thanks
for having me on. So we've interviewed folks
like Aubrey de Grey and others and everybody
seems to apply sort of different language
and vocabulary sometimes to talking about
dealing with aging. There's the idea of curing
aging. There's the idea of eliminating aging
or making aging obsolete as an example. Can
you talk a little bit about sort of your general
philosophy when it comes to the human lifespan
and the sort of way you talk about and think
about it?
Sure. Well, I'm not any more to list. Um,
I'm a, I'm a realist. I'm a scientist at Harvard
medical school grounded in, uh, research we've
been doing for over 25 years now. Uh, my view
though is that by tackling the major cause
of all diseases, uh, in our society or major
diseases which is aging, uh, we will have
a dramatic impact on those diseases and people's
longevity and how young they can stay into
the, the last five, 10, 15 years of their
lives.
And how much of the focus in your mind needs
to be on, or I guess when we think about the
approach that you take, is the idea to think
about aging as a condition that we are looking
to treat differently? Or is it more like,
for example, when we talk about cancer treatment,
we're really talking about a number of different
conditions each, each which needs or requires
a sort of a different approach depending on
the particular that particular as being, not
just the particulars of the condition, but
also the particulars of the individual that
we're looking to treat.
Well, about 10 years ago, the field that I'm
in, uh, longevity research, uh, we declared
that we had discovered the major hallmarks
of aging. And these are things like mitochondrial
dysfunction or energy decline, stem cell depletion
till new short name. There's a, there's a,
a group of them. And, uh, we were quite happy
for those years, but I've always been fascinated
in trying to find what's causing all of those
because they don't just happen to, has to
be, in my view, a unifying reason. Uh, and
that's what I think that, uh, I've come up
with, this is my best explanation in the book.
I described much of the evidence that we've
accumulated over 10 years. So what I think
is causing all of those various hole marks
is a loss of inflammation. The analog inflammation
in ourselves. And what that means is that
instead of having five 10 20 different medicines
to tackle each one of the whole marks of aging,
if I'm right, a single medicine could reverse
the aging process.
And what is the sort of, uh, physical way
in which this operates? What is it specifically
that is the process that you would be looking
to either undo, stop, or, or actually reverse?
Yeah. Well, only in the last few years we've
realized across all mammals, of course, including
ourselves, is what's called the DNA methylation
clock. We also call it the Horvath clock named
after my friend Steve Horvath. And if I took
your [inaudible], I could read how old you
are and even predict when you're going to
die. And these marks are part of the EPI genome.
Now we all know the, the, the genome very
well, but the epigenome is the layer above
that that regulates which genes are turned
on and off. The epigenomes is what allows
us to be, to go from a fertilized cell to
a a newborn of 26 billion cells, each one,
each tissue with thousands of different types
of cells in there. The epigenome I think is
what goes awry. As we get older, we lose the
epigenetic information and that's the analog
information of the cell. Now, anyone who's
had a record player or a cassette tape knows
that analog information is pretty useless
at preserving information and I think that's
also true for our bodies. Now the question
is, can you find a backup copy of that epigenetic
information to perform a reset of the cells?
And I think we've, we're coming very close
to being able to do that and we've already
got some, uh, some pretty interesting results
in mice already.
What's the mechanism through which that could
be done? Is it a, the delivery mechanism I'm
talking about, are we talking about a pill?
Are we talking about nanotechnology, et Cetera?
Yeah, well, it's only days. In fact, some
of this work is not even published yet. People,
listeners can find this online. We've posted
it. It's under peer review. There have been
others who have published work that shows
that you can also reset the clock. So how
do we currently do it? Well, the first way
it was done with TJ genetically modify mice.
That's obviously not going to help and that
was also toxic the way it worked out. We've
now packaged a set of three reprogramming
genes that uh, actually we, we use what are
called Yamanaka factors. Yamanaka genes. Uh,
Yamanaka won the Nobel Prize in 2012 the learning
how to make stem cells out of skin cells and
other adult cells in the body, but we use
them to reset the clock in the body. We don't
make stem cells. We push them partially back
to where they came from. We deliver them,
as you said, in a virus right now it's a viral
therapy. It would be used we think in the
eye initially, which is where the, a lot of
gene therapy is being applied in the clinic
right now to correct genetic diseases. So
we wouldn't be correcting genetic diseases
necessarily. We'd be using it to rewind the
clock and, and allow tissues and organs like
the eye to recover, uh, and become more youthful.
And in mice at least we've managed to restore
eyesight in old mice. [inaudible]
what's the timeline that understanding that
it's still very early that you, this may be
developed on and available?
Uh, well, I'm an entrepreneur. I'm many people
who know me know that very well. I've started
many companies over the years. There's a new
company that I'm working with, with Horvath.
Uh, a friend who I mentioned, a professor
at UCLA and myself and a professor, Bill Monte
who did the initial discovery that I'd mentioned
about reprogramming. We've come together to
make a go at this. We're going to be, uh,
hopefully treating the first patient in less
than two years from now. And our goal is to
treat glaucoma damage to the eye due to pressure.
And we think that that'll be, if we, if it
works the first of many treatments of turning
back the clock in various parts of the body
and hopefully eventually throughout the entire
body to have an age reset. [inaudible]
there are certain populations that have been
studied for their longevity. So there are,
uh, the carions there are a number of these
different populations that, that folks have
heard of that live longer on average, um,
than others. Can you talk a little bit about
whether in the work that you do, there is
significance to that? My understanding is
that much of their longevity is attributed
to lifestyle. It seems as though your work
is operating on a sort of different levels.
So do those populations have any research
value to you or are we really dealing with
something very, very different?
Uh, no, actually it all ties together. Um,
you know, if, if my theory didn't explain,
uh, the last hundred years of observation
and it wouldn't be a useful theory. So what
we, what we see and also predict, but what
we currently see is that, uh, a stable epigenomes
the ability to slow down that biological hook,
uh, does happen when societies and individuals
have those healthy lifestyles. Uh, being hungry
every day or every other day, uh, during a
lot of exercising, keeping active, keeping
the body in a state of high alert. These are
the things that slow down that epigenetic
clock that I believe is a driver, if not the
main cause of aging itself. Now, there are
also genes that we are either born of gene
variants that will, we're born with if we're
lucky, that predisposed to living over a hundred.
These are called centenarian families and
the variants in those [inaudible], Emily's
are part of this epigenetic regulatory network.
Uh, some of them are that we work on a cold
[inaudible] and the I in that Sirtuin name
stands for information. They're silent information
regulators and those are key players in this
epigenetic clock. And we can use various things
in our lives such as what we eat when we eat
and how much exercise we do among other things
I've put in my book to slow down that rate
of epigenetic clock. There are many others
that I talk about in my book and other things
that can be done, but we think these are central
regulators that are found throughout life
and have been with us since the beginning
of life.
Do you have a particular, um, diet and, or
supplement regimen that you, uh, adhere to?
And the reason I ask that is a lot of the
folks that work in the field that you work
in seem to have one, which sometimes is not
obviously directly related to the research
that the person seems to be doing. So it's
more of a curiosity.
Uh, well, yeah, my mind's more than a curiosity.
Um, the work that we do in my lab, uh, can
be translated into my, my family's lifestyle,
um, and what we take. Uh, of course I don't
recommend to my family that they take it,
but they're all scientists and they know what
the, what the data set suggests and the risks,
uh, far, far less than the potential reward.
And so the first, uh, discovery that we made
was that these are two in regulators of the
Epi genome, um, need a molecule called Nad.
And, uh, so that was back actually in 2002,
2003. Uh, so I take a nad boosting molecule
pills that, uh, I am hoping, uh, and that
evidence suggests will put my body in a state
of high alert, uh, as the wife being hungrier
and exercising than I otherwise have time
before, uh, resveratrol.
Uh, this was in the news back in 2003. We,
we discovered that resveratrol activates the
Sirtuin, uh, enzyme, uh, which is a protector
of the body and also a stabilizer of the epigenetic
clock. Uh, and so resveratrol from red wine.
I've been taking that. So it was my father
for over a decade now. Uh, we both have very
good health and so far so good, I should say,
by the way, because I'm a professor at Harvard
Medical School, I know that this is not a
clinical trial. It's not working. I'm going
to publish a, but I also know that that uh,
we've all been born probably generational
too, too, too early to know for sure if these
things work to extend healthy lifespan. And
so we do have to be ahead of the curve if
we're going to learn what these molecules
are actually doing. That said, all of these
molecules have been backed up by clinical
trials that are also running, um, typically
here at Harvard and also around the world.
And, uh, we, we know the safety before any
molecules are put into my body. Um, the last
one we studied was form and we worked with
Rafael de Cabo at NIH to show that mice that
are fed metformin, which is a diabetes drug,
a reasonably safe one taken by millions of
people around the world that was extensively
extended their lifespan certainly kept them
healthier in human studies. It looks like
in tens of thousands of patients that have
been studied, metformin slows down the aging
process, prevents cancer, heart disease for
and of course diabetes. And for that reason,
I take a triple combo of those things.
Very interesting stuff and I highly recommend
that folks in the audience, uh, pick up the
book lifespan, why we age and why we don't
have to. We've been speaking with the books,
author Davidson Claire,
who's a professor of genetics at Harvard Medical
School. David, really interesting having you
on and I so appreciate your time. Thanks David.
I appreciate it too.